こんにちわ！はじめしゃちょーです
率直に言います
まぁ、俺ぐらいの24の男になってくると
こうなんかこう、やっぱ
男らしさっていうのを求め出してきて
あの、分かるっしょ！男らしさ！
だから腕時計とか付けたんですけど
これから僕はどんどん大人の〜男性になるためには
もっとこう男らしくなりたくて
でまぁ、男らしいっつったらもう
たばこしかないっしょ！というわけで、えっと
僕ちょっと喘息持ちで
たばこ吸うと喘息発作が出ちゃって
たばこが吸えない身体なんですよ
いつだっけなぁ、なんかコンビニでバイトしてる時
あぁ、２０歳ですよ？
２０歳でコンビニでバイトしてる時に、
先輩から一本たばこを借りて、こう吸ってて
すいません一本借ります！ってこうやって
ってやって、一本吸った瞬間
_(´ཀ`」 ∠)_
あぶ…吐きそうになっちゃった…
_:(´ﾛ`」 ∠):_
ってなって
もうそれくらい、ちょっと多分たばこの煙に対しては
弱くて
たばこ吸いたいなとか言ってるんですけども
たばこ嫌いなんですよ
身体に悪いのとかできれば避けたいんで
喘息発作も出るし、
たばこ吸ってる人の近くにも居たくないぐらい
たばこ…ちょっと嫌いなんですけどもぉ！！！
たばこは吸いたい
という矛盾が生じております
分かる？
身体に害がなければ
たばこを吸いたいって思ってるんですよ
ベランダとかでこうやってやりたいわけですよ僕は
でもたばこは身体に良くないからやりたくない
そんな僕に奇跡が訪れた☆
はいこちら！
えーこれ
ビタシグっていう
たばこっぽいひとたち(?)らしいです
ちょ、ちょっと調べます
あ〜なんかたばこ吸いたい吸いたい言ってるんですけども
あの、たばこは絶対やめた方がいいです
僕の周り、吸ってる人結構少なめなんですけども
みんな揃って言うのはもう
まじでやめた方がいいみたいな
もうなんか、抜け出せなくなるらしいんで！
電子タバコなの…？
そ！あ！あの！あの！これこれ！ちょ！ちょ！ちょ、
これほんと凄いんですよ！！
ニコチン・タールとか有害物質が一切入ってないらしいです
これてか未成年吸っていいのかな？
そこが結構ポイントだと思います
あーなるほどね、なんか
Yahoo!知恵袋で見たんですけど
ニコチン・タールが入っていないから
違法ではないらしいんですけども
未成年がね、たばこっぽいの吸ってると
さすがに怪しいと思うので
検査させられるらしいので、あんまなんか
よろしくないみたいです！
未成年の人はやめておきましょうね！
てわけで、僕は大の大人なので
この全く一切、無害のたばこを
吸います！(歓喜)
これ凄いんですよ
ニコチン・タールを含んでいない
なんか栄養を、栄養が、栄養が、栄養
栄養が入ってるって！！！
ほんまやぁ…有害物質やなくて栄養が入っとる
味のタイプもすごいなんかいろいろフルーティなやつがありますな
えー凄いね、一応ね、電子タバコっていうアレらしいんですけど
ハイッハイッハイッ！
とりあえず吸いまーす！
あのーこんなこと言ってますけど
本当にたばこ嫌いで
たばこ吸ってる人いたら部屋から出るんですよ僕
だってさぁよく考えてみ？
あのなんかたばこ、多分結構有名な話なんですけども
主流煙と副流煙っていうのがあって
たばこ吸ってる人より周りにいる人の方が
ガンになる確率が上がるみたいな、こう煙とかでね
だからもう吸ってる自分より周りの人の方がこうなんか
人命に危機を侵されるみたいな
もぉ、あんまりよろしくないっすよ！
まぁ人に迷惑をかけないならいいと思うんですけども
周りにいる人〜にそういうちょっとアレはちょっと
よろしくないなとか思ってしまっています
あんまりたばこは好きじゃないんですけど
これならイイかもね！！
たばこを吸いたいというより、コレをしたいんで僕は
ちょっとバニラバニラ
バニラ吸ってみます
お、おぉ〜あ〜
あ〜！オシャレオシャレ
はい、こんなデザインになっております
あ〜も〜この持ってる手がカッコイイもんこの
成人向けの商品らしいですね
なんで未成年の方は〜っあ〜い
未成年の方は多分違法であっても吸わない方がいいと思われます
ニコチンとかタールとかが入ってないので
安全が保障された成分と天然成分のみを使用しています
安全だぁ！！！
ゥェェ俺もうもうこれでもうスパスパできるわけよ？！
やばいやばいやばい早くみんなに自慢したい！
よし、参る
ゥェェ本当に？！緊張するんだけど
ではいきます！
ハッ！良い匂いだ×3 (興奮気味)
やべやべぇ、まじかっけぇじゃん！
まじかっけぇなおい！(興奮気味)
オイ
焼きそばパン買って来いよ
やべやべやべやべやべぇ！！！
かっけぇなおい！！！！！
おいヤベェぞヤベェぞヤベェぞ、マジ卍
鼻から吸えるのかな？
あ"あっつ！！
あっつ！！待って
あっつ×5
あ〜なるほど